startling new numbers to show you how
dire the crisis is at the southern
border nearly 7 000 migrant encounters a
day for the past three months this is
the fate of title 42 policy protections
remain uncertain some in Congress are
now pleading with the White House to
step up Texas representative Tony
Gonzalez joins us now there are a record
high number of Migrant encounters you
wouldn't know it if you ever listened to
a news conference coming out of the
White House but they have been reported
at the border since the start of fiscal
year 2023 that's October 1st as of
Thursday 600
000 over 600 000 total migrant
encounters at the border a new record
for the months of October November and
December over 186 000 were expelled
under title 42 leaving the majority of
over 430 000 released there's the
problem title 42 is still in place right
but this Administration has not utilized
it the way it was intended under the
Trump Administration when it actually
worked why is is that
uh good morning Julie yeah the the the
reality is this is exactly what the
administration wants what we're seeing
unfold is their plan uh one of the
things that we have to do we as
Republicans as just Americans is is to
push the administration to go this is
not normal what is happening at the
border is not normal nor should it be
normal it's as if the administration
wants everyone to think that this is a a
typical thing that occurs no it's the
debt of winter and you've got record
numbers of people coming over there is
nothing normal about what's happening at
the southern border nothing normal about
the number of terrorists uh potential
terrorists coming over fentanyl uh and
you know the the list goes on and on as
Republicans we have to push back and let
them know that things have to change and
it starts with border security let's
talk about the godaways in the past 90
days uh CBP observed over 240 000
godaways that's an average of roughly 2
600 per day Congressman Henry Cuellar a
Democrat from Texas a Democrat from
Texas I'm going to say it twice to takes
a swipe at Progressive White House
staffers for blocking efforts to handle
the Border crisis watch this
the administration just can't say
Congress through the immigration reform
they have the power to do policy right
now but they just you know quite
honestly I think the uh Homeland
Security Department is struggling with
some of the more Progressive White House
staffers and I hope Homeland wins this
particular fight I can't understand why
Progressive White House staffers would
have any say on what is honestly one of
the largest uh humanitarian crises in
this country that and the number of
fentanyl deaths which I could talk about
every single day hoping that the White
House would somehow respond and they
simply do not and they're worried about
politics and progressives when people
are dying
yeah Congressman Cuellar uh like myself
has a district along the border and what
is happening is essentially him and I
are contacting uh Customs and Border
Patrol uh literally daily and and trying
to work uh directly with the source to
get some of these holes filled it really
shouldn't be that way the administration
should be doing its job which they're
not but I'll remind everyone you know
it's it's time for Congress to lead
House Republicans now now will have the
majority and we got to stop just uh
bringing to light all these issues
that's important but we got to start
fixing them and you know uh the power of
the purse resides in the house so
there's opportunities for House
Republicans to start by uh by funding
border security one of those measures is
uh is Operation stone garden funds these
are funds that go directly to uh
sheriffs and Law Enforcement Officers
along the border that are doing a lot of
the heavy lifting that account hasn't
been increased during this Biden
Administration there's others do uh like
the wall and some other things that make
sense but it's time for House
Republicans to lead and through the
Appropriations process is I believe the
best way to do it title 42 was
potentially going to expire this week so
it was extended and then when President
Biden was asked about it he just
nonchalantly was like ah I mean this is
literally his response I'm paraphrasing
but oh yeah I guess they're extended it
till I guess June so I suppose we've got
some time to figure things out they're
not trying to figure anything out that's
the problem I mean what is being done
right now the president is on vacation
in the Caribbean Congress hasn't made
any decisions so who's the backbone of
the root of the problem because it ain't
Kamala Harris
yeah one of the one of the issues is uh
it's like this Administration is a
sleight of hand they want you to be
looking at one side while they're you
know with their right hand sealing
everything out of the cookie jar one of
the things that they've done is the when
these policies get overturned by the
courts is they don't enforce them so one
of the things that a new majority in the
Congress needs to do is to ensure that
title 42 and other policies are being
enforced there's nothing more dangerous
to this country than Catch and Release
when someone comes over and they just
get released in our country with no uh
repercussions that only encourages more
over 100 I've hosted over 100 members of
Congress uh that have come down and see
it you've got many new members like Zach
Nunn from Iowa and and Derek van Orton
from Wisconsin Juan system on Arizona
these are new members that are already
up to speed on the border on day one
you're gonna see House Republicans
really push to secure this order
starting with the Appropriations process
we look forward to it Congressman Tony
Gonzalez thank you very much for coming
on Happy New Year thank you Julie Rich
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis